- Alright, what entertainment
do you have for me today, internet?
Cat photo, cat photo.
Rant about people responding
to a tragedy incorrectly.
Cat photo.
(gasps)
Jerry T. Lewins said Star
Battles is the worst franchise
of all time, anyone who
watches it is a moron?
No, I will not engage.
No matter how wrong he is.
He said Princess Corenza is
a sad excuse for a character
and belongs in the kitchen?
Deep breath.
Instead of responding, I
can go get a cup of tea
and calm my nerves.
(whoosh)
(squeaking)
(calming music)
(upbeat electronic music)
Lukins is the worst director of all time!
Are you kidding me?
OK, OK.
Calm down.
Maybe it's time for a little walk.
(calming music)
He said what?
You know what, I'll
finally finish my novel.
(intense electronic music)
(calming music)
(beep)
No.
I'll take up crocheting,
like I've always wanted to.
(calming music, followed by intense music)
I'll adopt a baby, and raise
her in a good household
until she's 18 and I send
her off to a great college.
(calming music)
(beep)
Goddamit!
I'll train for the
astronaut program at NASA.
Get accepted, fly to Mars,
start a colony up there.
Wow, this place is beautiful.
Almost forgot why I came
up here to begin with.
Wow, I get service up here, too.
(beep)
Ah.
(bleep)
(intense electronic music)
You, Mr. Jerry T. Lewins,
are an incredible idiot.
Not only did Star Battles
inspire a generation,
Princess Corenza was the
first female character
in history to ever kill a man
with her bare hands on film,
so she is more progressive
and creative than anything
you could imagine, you thoughtless swine.
(beeping)
I immediately regret this.
(intense electronic music)
(whoosh)
(squeaking)